Anna is in Dallas Texas hi Anna welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show hi what's up so
you're really going to be the defining
factor in this I am on a diet program
and it is a very expensive diet program
it feeds me four meals a day and I just
make one meal on my own and my husband
and I were trying to obviously snowball
that we're trying to get out that and he
telling me I need to give this up and of
course I'm terrified of doing it because
it's really helping me lose weight and
much of your lousy 30 pounds great how
long you been doing it since February
okay how much more do you need to lose
thirty more okay so you'll be done by
Christmas hopeful actually I'll tell me
I'll be done before then like maybe
October yeah no and how expensive is it
like right now I can get it at the
lowest is 245 but if I need like a full
month's worth of food to you know four
times a day then it's about 350 per
month per month yes yeah and your
household income is what let me do the
math room click on that right now
between both my husband and I he made 50
600 a month okay and how old are you I'm
28 okay and you're talking about
scheduled to lose 60 pounds what was
your start weight 200 and so you're
going down to 140 I'm trying yes yeah I
would like 130 but I'll settle for 140
you said your hold again 28 okay all
right and how long has it been since you
were small Wow like honestly I rather be
my high school weight but that wasn't
like the healthiest choice I would like
to be 120 again but I know that's
probably not even physically so it's
been since high school basically yes
almost 10 years
I think you ought to stick with it okay
I think the benefits to your marriage to
your career to your health to the way
you feel about yourself your mental
health your spiritual walk I think the
benefits to all of that I think you're
awesome I'm so proud of you thank you I
appreciate that in your situation I
think it's worth every penny you're
spending you're succeeding at it the
trick is you know is to keep it off
right exactly and like that's the whole
point of this program too is for that
way you can keep it off slowly but
surely but the thing is the slower it
takes the more it's going to stay off
yeah but it's a you know as they all say
it's a lifestyle change it's not just
exactly and that's what it's preparing
me for is a lifestyle change yeah but I
the the financial benefit over the next
decade is going to far outweigh the
three more months or four more months of
$350 mm-hmm inhale I just in health care
if nothing else because the cost of
obesity and your health is unbelievable
yes exactly and we have so many health
issues in our family now the level of
energy you have to you know for your
career for your kids your your your
spouse or for yourself you know it
changes everything and so I mean there's
a whole lot more going on inside of you
right nothing simply having shed some
pounds am i right yes exactly yeah this
is very important I'm so glad you're
doing it yes I would spend this money if
I were in your shoes okay well thank you
so much I appreciate your opinion Thanks